[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
dealing with chronic pain on how she can
be well and whole and grieve the life
she's missing we talked to a woman who's
ready to leave her abusive marriage and
we talked to another woman whose
sister-in-law just won't leave stay
tuned
[Music]
what's up what's up this is jon with the
dr john deloney show
this is take 150.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm not having a good morning kelly
james what is that i'm
not doing a great job
hold up let's just get to the to the
point here welcome to the show if you're
new this isn't how we start most shows
normally i say things like hey welcome
we talk about mental health
relationships i'm so glad you're here
you're handsome
brilliant beautiful i'm glad that we're
walking with you i say all that kumbaya
stuff and then i tell you the number is
1-844-693-3291
if you want to be on the show it's
1-844-693-3291
go to johndaloney.com
ask go to johndaler.com
join the newsletter by redefining
anxiety i tried to do all that stuff
but today holy smokes
so we batch these shows and so we will
we will record a couple of shows right
in a row
so
sometimes when i'm like hey good morning
everybody it's the first show
hey everybody it's good to see you it's
the afternoon and we're recording the
first one this is not the first one this
is the second show
and that last show
not my finest work everybody
it was a great
are you sure that was only one show it
feels like it was a hundred shows why
because it took 119 takes to just do the
teaser
that little part at the beginning of the
show it's like on today's show we talk
about
i i don't know what happens
well it is it's tough because at the end
of the show you have to summarize the
calls that we had at the beginning like
during the show and you have to do it in
like 15 seconds
and we have like a countdown timer and
you have to just summarize it kind of on
the fly
and sometimes it you know you're one
take wonder but sometimes sometimes it
takes three or four
rarely does it take 906
i feel like we've recorded five shows
today and we've got one
one
that's okay we're amassing a stellar
blooper reel for the end of the year
dude i will never be able to work
anywhere else one day i'm gonna be like
hey i got a great opportunity i'm gonna
go get president of a college and james
you'll go
no you're not and i'll be like yeah i
know i am and then you'll say
i'm just gonna send you something in
your email box and then you'll just send
a blooper reel to which i will then call
that college and say thank you but no
thanks i'm a youtuber from here on out
that's just the job or a podcast or a
radio or whatever
to the wonderful sarah who edits this
poor thing
i'm sorry
just pick a restaurant you and your
lovely husband y'all can just go i don't
even oh geez let's go to rose in denver
colorado
near
four
what's up rose wherever you are how's it
going
okay how about you do people just sing
that to you all the time
not really because that [ __ ] that show
was
like a long time ago
oh geez i'm a [ __ ] so what's up rose
how's it going
it's going okay
um
so i am 28 years old and i was fairly
recently diagnosed with fibromyalgia oh
i am just trying to figure out how to
navigate this whole chronic illness life
thing how long have you bounced around
from doctor to doctor to symptom to
symptom before somebody finally
gave you a diagnosis
um
looking back i'm pretty sure i've had it
for at least the last 10 to 15 years
when i was in high school we tried to
figure out what was going on and i
bounced around a few doctors and
eventually just like gave up and decided
the symptoms weren't that bad
then
during covid it kind of struck me as
weird that like you mean it's not normal
to have all these random symptoms every
day and so and and things started
getting worse so i bounced around for
about a year-ish maybe six months until
we've nailed it down this time
so for people who don't know
give us a couple of things that you
experience on a regular basis that other
people wouldn't notice when they meet
you at a coffee shop
um so some of the main ones for me i
always have a sore throat like that it's
just like i don't even know what it
would feel like to not have some sort of
sore throat
uh
um
i have a lot of muscle aches and pains a
lot of fatigue
uh standing is really hard for me i
can't stand for very long periods of
time so like you know
i just have to sit down more often than
most people would
i'm sorry you're going through that
i hate that for you chronic pain man
jeez louise i can't wrap my head around
it i just know my neck hurts for a few
weeks because i did something stupid
it just affects everything right or like
when you
smash your toe or something or you have
a tooth that hurts it just affects
everything just can't imagine waking up
every day like that and ma'am
um
let me ask you this
tell me about your childhood
was it chaotic was it
fun was it
was there challenges there tell me about
it
i mean a little bit of all of it
definitely was chaotic in some respects
uh
had very hands-on involved parents um
my brother
what's that overly involved
at times
um uh my brother has a lot of health
problems and so his kind of and his were
more obvious than mine uh where he would
be in the hospital for weeks at a time
and so that kind of like what
uh no they never really did figure out
all of it they finally diagnosed him
with some neurological stuff
um
but he would go for
like weeks at a time where he would be
in like
excruciating
pain
or where his muscles would just lock up
where he like couldn't bend his leg or
that kind of thing
um
and
like i said he would be in and out of
the hospital quite a bit from doctor to
doctor so so has anybody ever and i i
want to ask you this and this is
you can and i know people do this to
folks who are diagnosed with
fibromyalgia all the time so this is me
walking with you is that cool
okay trust me there um anytime i hear of
a family
a system
that have
recurring migraines recurring
um
um
chronic pain issues
um recurring asthma issues i always want
to there's always the environmental
thing right is there mold in the house
and things like that
but i also wonder
what is the is there any contributing
chaos is there a chance that this is the
bodies trying to respond to
dysfunctional relationships to
um is this the body's way of responding
to chaos
is an overactive inflammatory response
system or a overreactive all the fighter
flights are up and it comes out this way
or that way or does that make sense
has anyone ever talked to you or your
brother about
um stress cycles or when this stuff
flares up it happens to be around
seasons when you've got a lot going on
or covid for instance or
your mom
acted a certain way your dad was super
overly invite does that make sense is
there anything environmental that may
have contributed to some of this
um yeah i definitely think there there
were some things here and there
that uh in my childhood that definitely
and even just now i know that
one of my triggers for flares
is stress like if i'm upset about
something or if i'm really stressed out
about something that's one of my biggest
flare triggers to cause it to get really
bad
do you have a good relationship with
your parents
um it's been a little rocky the last
year or two it was uh we were really
close growing up but last year or two
it's been a little harder were you close
growing up in a
equal partnership um not your equal they
were your parents obviously but in a way
that they honored and loved you or
was it a good relationship because you
did everything they said exactly the way
they wanted it done
and you performed well
yeah closer to the latter
okay
um
this is i've got no research to back up
what i'm saying here so i don't want to
be a youtube conspiracy nerd or have
like the i'm telling you the podcast
that nobody will talk about this right
but
um
overactive immune responses i've seen
and or heard about
in performative child-parent
relationships
i've seen that in abusive child-parent
relationships i've seen it in neglectful
not neglectful like you there's no food
and water but not but neglectful in
nobody ever just looked their kid in the
eye looked you in the eye and said
i'm so
glad that you're my daughter
and
in an effort to solve some of that i
wonder if the body just spins itself up
and sometimes that looks like adhd and
sometimes that looks like it depends on
your genetic cocktail is in your
environment and partners in a pear tree
all that to say is this i don't care how
you got where you are you're here now
right
yeah and so um
thank you for letting me just ask those
questions i'm always just curious when
i'm when i'm walking that walking back
with somebody who experiences this so
how can i help you directly
so i was wondering um i know kind of
twofold question uh i know you've talked
a lot about grief on the show and
kind of like that idea of
like
holding a ceremony or writing letters or
whatever you need to do to mourn the
fact that my life just doesn't look the
way i thought it would
um but i was wondering if you could
speak more to what that looks like when
it's
it's not a once and done loss but it's
just this kind of living in uncertainty
where i never know how i'm going to feel
from day to day and there's it's
impossible to try to make plans because
i have no idea how i'm going to be
feeling in a week you know yeah um like
all the little losses you know
absolutely love that question
you just nailed on the chronic pain
loop-de-loop spiral of death
which is this
um let's say that you have some genetic
stuff
which i think would be fair because your
brother experiences too
some environmental stuff
and if we really got deep with
relationships with your family with your
brothers and sisters but
we'd probably find some stuff all that
fair
okay
so you end up with a an overactive
pain system pain detection system let's
just say it like that
i'm trying to
not be a nerd here
and so
you are left wondering can i make plans
can i go out i'm just going to stay at
home
i can't eat that cause that makes me
feel like this i can't even turn on the
news and suddenly you start curating
your life in tighter and tighter circles
and you stop hanging out with other
people you stop laughing you stop having
fun you stop having spontaneous joy
nobody wants to like have sex with their
spouse when
they don't feel good when their throat
hurts all the time when they got
headaches you know what i mean with
their neckers
and so what does our body do
it sounds the alarms
we need connection we need those
relationships we need meaningful work we
need peace
we need sleep we need movement and
exercise
which are things that chronic pain takes
from us and so what happens it spins up
the alarms and the chronic pain
accelerates
is this your experience
yes yes
so
here's the cornerstone key
put everything anchor everything into
this one thing
you have to make peace with your body
it's at war with you
and you cannot return
fire for fire
and how do you do that
you start being curious about your body
not pissed off
you start being
curious and inquisitive i wonder why my
throat hurts today
what is there something stressful that i
eat something
not
son of a my throat hurts now i can't go
to the you see the difference
one keeps your frontal lobe engaged one
says i'm safe i'm fine
my legs hurt and i can't i gotta sit
down why'd i gotta sit down today what's
stressful in my environment today that
is starting to spin me up a little bit
that is different than
that rage
i wish i could just stand up for a whole
concert i'd have to sit down like
everybody else now i got to get seats
back here he's not or she's not going to
want to sit with me because i they want
to stand up and i'm not going to go to
the show
you see what i'm saying
so anchoring in
i'm going to make peace with this
my guess is i may be crazy i may be
crazy i'm not a fibromyalgia expert i'm
going gonna connect with somebody in
fact my buddy who's a medical doctor
here i'm gonna sit down while we're here
he's here this weekend we'll sit over
dinner i'd like to learn more about this
but i know you have to have connection
i know that
some shape form or fashion you've got to
sleep
that says tells your body we're okay
you've got to have community a laughter
you've got to be engaged with other
people
you've got to figure out ways to move
your body even if it's just a little
walk maybe you can't crush a crossfit
exorcist workout ever but can you go for
a walk
can you just move your arms right can
you
i don't know do yoga what what are those
practices
how can i make peace with my body and so
sometimes when we
are writing letters to ourselves to deal
with childhood trauma
we are acknowledging
we're not so much making peace we are
staring it down
we are turning and facing that forest
fire as terrence real says
this is different
these are letters to yourself man i
wonder why today is this is i'm feeling
like this do you feel the difference
there
yeah
and then grief comes
when you wake up that morning and you've
made plans because you've leaned into it
and you can't get up and go then you
grieve i have to miss that concert
tonight
so frustrated i'm sad
have pre-grieving something assures you
that your body's gonna respond in an
elevated with an elevated stress
response
do you get what i'm saying
yeah don't pre-grieve
don't pre-hate don't don't uh
what do you call them what was the thing
that we did
in uh when
preemptive war don't go to preemptive
war on your body
yeah
do you do that
yeah
yeah
and so you know who loves you
your body
and when your body detects it's at war
it goes to war back
and war hurts
and you have an elevated sense of
pain
is this so annoying i feel like i'm just
being annoying
no no it makes sense
yeah and it's frustrating i know
when is the time you haven't hurt do you
remember a time
not really
because like i said it like looking back
the symptoms go back all the way to at
least high school probably younger than
that even yeah have you ever met with a
counselor
yeah i i've been seeing a counselor
trying to work through some of the stuff
with my family okay and then through you
know
like i actually met with her last night
and i was kind of we're actually kind of
talking similar things there where i'm
like i feel like i'm wasting more energy
trying to
avoid
having a flare then
if i would just
let it go and
if it happens it happens if it doesn't
it doesn't you know so can i tell you do
you you just saying that
makes me smile
you got
um
a different set of cards than most
people
some people got three aces dealt to him
right out of the deck
and some people got like a two and a
five and a seven
right
we can't always you know we can we can't
we can't go back and redeal the cards we
deal with the ones we got
and what i want you to do is to make
peace with rose
and can i tell you this if nobody's ever
told you this i'm glad you're around
thank you
like i'm glad you're
kicking it there in denver
do you have friends
uh yes
do you have are you
are you married are you engaged you date
anybody
no no i'm uh single but i
just in the last few months was able to
get connected with a group of people at
a church near me that
uh
like they meet every week and they've
been really supportive awesome
so can i tell you you're worth having
friends
you're worth being friends with
you will bring value to
friends
and one day if you choose to
match eye sparkles with somebody
they'll they'll be blessed to have you
in their life too
thank you all of this starts with i'm
not going to war with my body anymore
i'm gonna make peace
and i'm gonna go ahead and buy the
concert ticket and i'm gonna go ahead
and buy the plane ticket and i'm gonna
go ahead and say for sure i'm ready to
go to coffee tomorrow
and then if there's a flare-up then you
say i can't make it body's taken off on
me again
and if it happens every time you're
about to get coffee maybe there's some
social anxiety there maybe there's some
disconnection you need to lean into or
that can be something that you can talk
about with your counselor let's iso when
when did my body start to have these
flare-ups what's going on in my world is
it when i find myself owing a lot of
money so if i'm when i find myself
wherever i happen to be
lean into those things lean into those
things
i'm grateful for you thank you so much
for the call rhodes we'll be right back
on the dr john delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john deloney show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right we are back let's go to jolene
in baton rouge louisiana what's up
jolene
hey how are you outstanding how are you
i'm great excellent so how can i help
what's going on
um i've got a question i've been married
for 27 years and um i i think i'm done
i'm kind of working on a divorce plan um
and i hate it i don't want to do that
but um
and i want to know how i can help my
kids
how come why are you done
what happened
um
it's been going on for a long time um
we we've run business together and
now i'm i'm kind of doing it on my own
and he has another job and um i just
it was pretty good before we had kids um
and he's uh you know after we had kids
he just he wouldn't help at all with the
kids he kind of just we would work side
by side with the business all day and
come home at the end of the day and he
would grab a beer and go sit on the
couch and everything was left up to me
and so i just kind of dealt with it and
i got really resentful for a long time
um my kids are 14 and 16. and um
when i was pregnant with my youngest
i asked him you know i kind of had a
breakdown i said i'm really tired i
can't do this by myself
i really need you to help me and um you
know i mean i just i need you to
participate and and be part of the
family
and um and i don't know where he came up
with this but he told me he said you
know i'm just a bad dad i'm just a bad
husband you need to find somebody that
makes you happy
and
you know i didn't know what to think you
know and the first thing i did was say
you know no you're not a bad dad you're
not a bad husband
you know i just i just need some help
and um he's
i know he had a really bad childhood um
there was a lot of abuse there he
watched his dad abuse his mom and um and
they're still together so um
you know and
i just i don't know how to deal with
some of the things he's saying i don't
really feel safe with him anymore
and so
i i feel like i've got to kind of work
this out and and make a plan in private
like you know on on my own and not
really let him know what's going on and
i feel really bad about that you know
doing that on my own and not
not telling him but i just i feel like i
have to
and um and my kids have seen some things
they probably shouldn't have what have
they seen and
um
they've seen him i know this is my
oldest but um
he
and i'm sorry i've never told this i've
never said anything to anybody about
this before i've kind of kept it myself
um
everybody thinks she's a great guy and
we have a great marriage and and it has
been for the most part but there's been
some pretty dark things that have
happened what did your son see
we got an argument one night um i just
didn't feel like having sex i wasn't in
the mood i was trying i asked him to put
a different movie on or something he got
mad got an argument
i went to go sleep on the couch
and he came out and um started choking
me put his hand on my face
and my son woke up and saw it and told
him to quit hurting mommy
and um
that was a long time ago and that
doesn't happen very often but um
you know he just
jolene
jolene yeah yeah
take a big deep breath and hold it
okay hold it
hold it three
two let it go
now your shoulders are bunched up around
your ears right now and you just drop
them down
okay
okay
you don't have to apologize for him
you don't have to make this
you don't have to minimize this
you're not you're not bad
you're not broken
you're married to somebody who hurts you
yeah
and you're married to somebody who's
hurting your kids either directly or
indirectly
yeah
and does he have some demons oh
absolutely
yeah he does hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on you're coming to
his defense you're running to his
defense he doesn't need you to defend
him
okay
he's got demons for sure
but that's a context not an excuse
he doesn't get to hurt jolene
jolene's worth being loved
jolene's worth sleeping all night
feeling safe
yeah jolene's worth not feeling like
having sex sometimes
jolene's not is worth not worrying about
her boys being safe
okay
hey
have you ever said the words out loud
i'm done to anybody other than me
no
okay thank you for sharing that
thank you go figure go home right
i will share it with everybody
you can't do this by yourself do you
have somebody that's walking alongside
you
um
i've got an appointment with the
counselor next week
um and i'm i'm doing all that behind his
back which makes me feel really guilty
but um i need to i i love him jolene
yeah yeah
you are not safe
oh no
there's nothing to feel guilty about
now i will never tell somebody you
should get divorced
i know i'm not ever going to do that i
don't even want to come back and say i
did this because you told me to
but you're not safe
and you haven't been safe for a long
time
you need to go talk to somebody today
okay i need an appointment with the
counselor i need you to talk to your
lawyer today i don't know what you start
thinking about divorce i'm thinking
about
if you're down this road you need to go
talk to a professional
and be on the way
in your head if you start adding it up
and thinking about it and building it up
building it up you're having
conversations in your head that nobody
else hears
yeah
but that disconnection that annoyance
that resentment
that starts to be felt everywhere your
kids feel it and your husband feels it
your clients feel it your customers
everybody feels it
and that's where we get a lot of
problems that's where we get the
blow-ups and the whoa where did that
come from and people say things they can
never take back and they do things they
can never take back
when you first started this call you
said i think i'm done so i'll ask you
directly are you done
i am i don't want it i don't want i
don't i know i know i don't know i know
i know i know and nobody wants this
and what made me start to feel that way
is i got to thinking i don't want to be
married to him when my kids are grown up
and gone
i just don't and then i felt bad for
feeling like i'm standing behind them
and making them
um
you know i guess protect me because
they're around he's you know i guess
that puts the brakes on some stuff
sometimes and it doesn't happen very
often but um but it happens
yeah it happens and um and and the
threat of it happening
is violent too
the cloud of
it could go off at any moment
is violence
12 year olds step walking on their tippy
toes because they don't know when dad's
gonna set off on mom is violence
yeah
and i've i've come to my kids defense
too and then they apologize for me
getting you know for for them dragging
me into it you gotta get out jolene
yeah you're not safe or he's got to go
and
somewhere along the way
somebody told you that your feelings
didn't count
that your job was to make sure everybody
else was okay
and i may be the first person to ever
tell you this
but what's happening to you is not okay
and you don't have a thing to feel
guilty for
and nobody wanted this
you'll grieve that later
you'll grieve the crap out of this later
but today is about safety
today's about my boys will not see this
my boys will not have to get between
their dad and their mom ever again
my boys will not walk through this house
and wonder is dad gonna
smack one of them
how do i talk to them why may i
i don't want them to grow up and be the
same way i want to put a stop to this
right now but i don't want to run their
dad down to them
julianna
they already know that
they already know
your young son already had to say daddy
quit hurting mom
they know yeah
what they need is a different picture
about what dignity and respect and
treating a wife actually looks like and
they don't have that picture
no
of a woman that says no more
this is what love looks like this is
what connection looks like this is what
it feels like to have a good night's
sleep and not worry about whether
something bad is gonna happen to mom
they've never felt that
ever
and so the greatest thing you can do for
your boys right now is be safe
because they are absorbing a hurricane
inside that house
yeah
you've heard the old uh fight or flight
you know that was designed for when a
bear came to a cave
dr nadine burke harris she's got a great
story that she talks about
you know the bear came to the cave and
your body's designed to go into fight or
flight
but it's designed for a quick burst
happens really fast and then it's over
you either kill that bear you run away
from that bear or that bear eats you
that's about how that thing's designed
we don't have a biological system for
what happens when that bear moves in the
house
and we are on fight or flight every day
every minute of every week
and you deserve better than that your
boys deserve better than that
and
i hope this isn't controversial your
husband deserves better than that
yeah no he he does i just i don't know
how to help him that's not your job i'm
leaving him behind but
honey
he left you a long time ago
i know
he left you a long time ago
and now you have to be the grown-up once
again and go through the paperwork
and figure out what the finances are
going to look like and how the business
is going to get split up and it's going
to be hell
yeah that's what i'm telling you got to
have somebody walk with you not just a
counselor but you got to have some
friends do you have some friends that
you can count on
i really don't all of our friends are
are both of our friends and they think
he's a great guy and i'm just
i don't know i'm afraid they're going to
take sides you know because they don't
see what what we see they will and that
still doesn't mean you don't do the
right thing
yeah i don't say the right thing that
sounded like i was getting onto you
i'm like doing a safe thing
yeah okay
and
i'm heartbroken for you but you know
it's the so answer your question
what are the things how do you talk to
your boys
you tell them
mommy has not been safe you don't have
to mention your husband at all mommy's
not been safe
and we are going to find we're going to
either live here without dad or
we're going to get a new place however
that plays out that's between you and
the lawyers and the mental health
professionals and all that
yeah
but we're going to go to a place where
we're safe
and we're going to develop a set of
family values that we're going to live
by
and
there's going to be problems in school
because they're going to lash out and
you're going to love them and connect
with them and hold them accountable
and they're going to struggle
academically they're going to struggle
socially all those things are going to
happen and you know that you're not
going to get frustrated be caught off
guard by it
because they grew up in a an abusive
household
and you're going to continue to love
them you're going to continue to hold
them accountable and you're going to
have to figure out groups in your
community you have to figure out
connection in your community
and this is going to be hard and in this
case heart is right
okay you deserve safety jolene
you deserve love
you deserve to be able to laugh
and be able to say
not tonight honey i'm not feeling it
and not have some man's hands around
your throat
yeah
do you believe me
i do okay
i do i just i know it's gonna be really
really hard it's gonna suck it is but
it's also gonna be
i don't think you fully exhaled in years
probably not i know you haven't
and
i want you to make one switch for me
okay
okay
you're a peacekeeper
that's why people love you you make sure
everybody else has something to eat you
make sure everybody else's drink is full
you make sure everybody else is you go
to somebody else's house for dinner and
you help them clean up am i right
yes yeah
i want you for the first time in your
life
to start treating jolene like you treat
everybody else
okay
you are worthy of you loving you
you're worthy of saying
no that hurts you cannot do that
you are worthy of saying you will not
talk to our boys that way you will not
hit our kids you will not hit me in
front of those kids i will not let them
grow up in this environment
i will let you be a grown-up and figure
out how you're going to pay rent how
you're going gonna find your own place
that is up to you
as for me and my house we're gonna be
safe and we're gonna have peace and
we're gonna have laughter back and we're
gonna open the shades back
i want you to start treating jolene like
you treat everybody else deal
deal
thank you so much for your bravery thank
you so much for your call
i cannot i cannot tell you this enough
julian
get somebody to walk alongside you today
even if it's one of those friends that
you're like on the fence one of those
friends has a wife
who knows
one of those friends has a wife
or
somebody who
just has their suspicions
reach out and
sit down with that person and say i need
you to walk alongside me because things
are about to get messy for a season
and we'll be with you the whole way
julian don't hesitate to give me a call
i'll be right back on the doctor john
delaney
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen you are not broken and i'm living
proof that you can get your life back i
wrote this book so everyone could read
it not just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndaloni.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right we are back we're gonna go to
elsa in oh gosh oklahoma city
what's up elsa
oh hi how are you i'm good as a texan
we're just raised to hate oklahoma city
it's just kind of part in the dna but
i'll go with it this one time what's up
elsa
oh hi so i have a question
my sister-in-law had been living with us
for five past years
uh five years and she recently moved out
earlier this year she went to my
sister-in-law house because she bought a
house and she was renting out a room to
help with the mortgage
um
turns out that
last week she called my husband and told
him that my
sister-in-law's husband
was sexually harassing her
and
and now she my husband wants to move
wants her to move back with us
and the thing is that i want to live by
myself i want us to live by ourselves
no way elsa what are you talking about
i don't want to have people
how old is she
uh she's 28.
why doesn't she get her own place
the thing is that we are from colombia
and in our community
uh if you are a woman you don't get out
of the house until you're married
and
he feels like if she moves out on her
own first of all she doesn't make enough
money to pay the rent on her own and
second of all
he's scared that something bad might
happen to her because she's a woman and
she's going to be on her own and i also
feel guilty
because she's going through a hard time
with all of the things that are going on
sure i feel guilty that if something
happens to her because she's living on
her own
and
you know there's a lot of bad people
in the world that if something happens
to her i'll feel guilty but at the same
time
i just want my own space my privacy
absolutely
whoo number one thank you for the call
elsa
you are awesome thank you for the call
thank you for being honest i know this
is hard
and
i don't want to make light of this um
because i think it's real and it's
beautiful and it's messy
is the weight of
culture and cultural expectations and
every culture is different
uh
some cultures say
your parents they can get a home if they
didn't plan they're gonna be homeless
other cultures are like no mom and dad
gonna live with us that's just the way
that happens
and and some cultures are
um very
very very paternalistic i haven't heard
it to this degree i've heard it with
younger women i've never heard it with a
28 year old
well that yeah 20 because she um
she moved here five years ago and that's
why she was living with us and
if we decide not to take her in first of
all my husband is very upset that i
don't want her back sure
and he's calling me a bad person that
i'm mean that i'm very selfish
and that's getting to me because now i
feel guilty and i'm
i'm thinking well maybe i'm a bad person
maybe i should let her move back in
and also my my my mother-in-law and my
father-in-law if they're back in
colombia but if if they they don't know
what's going on but whenever they find
out and they they they know that we
don't want her back
yeah they're gonna be um very upset with
my husband
all right so have you ever heard of the
word boundaries
oh
john i'm i'm learning to put boundaries
to to learn to to to do that with myself
because i feel like my husband takes
advantage of my lack of boundaries good
okay
so um are you first gen were you born in
colombia are you born in the states yes
no um i we move here from colombia okay
so i want to tell you the international
students that i've worked with over the
years
as they would come from wherever they
came from all these remarkable places
all over the world they would i loved
having them in my classes i loved having
them in my student groups because they
brought such a rich new perspective to
how the world works
and the things that my um
american students would would just take
as well this is just the way this is it
was always so great to have a different
perspective
and
i loved watching my international
students gain a different perspective
and they ended up saying
i like my own space
yeah i
i don't like sharing a bathroom with
another woman who's my
husband i want to be the most important
woman in his life not third behind his
mom that lives in another country
and his sister that lives in the other
room right that's how i feel like like
his family's first and i'm just second
yes
and so
are you ready for that conversation
that's gonna be hard and it might blow
up everything or do you want to just
swallow it and say this is the lot in
life i've got and ride on into the
sunset
okay so part of me wants to just give in
and have her move back with us but i
know that i'm gonna have your resentment
yes and part of you
wants your own house with your own
husband and you want to be
recklessly in love with him and not have
to worry about his sister walking in on
you and you want to not live under the
shadow of his parents who live in
another country and you want to be able
to make your own grown-up decisions for
your own grown-up family
right yes but also part of me feels like
i'm always thinking that things are
gonna happen and i feel like okay what
if she gets hurt by someone because she
lives on her own that's right that's
called catastrophizing that is you are
always looking at what i do all the time
i know i know but what if what if that
happens i'm i'm gonna feel guilty
so elsa
you're gonna feel guilty if you don't do
anything and you just let your life go
by it's the third place
the third woman in line
for your husband
you're gonna feel guilty
if
you tell your husband hey i
what if we got married i mean now we've
been married five years what if it was
just us for a season right you're gonna
feel guilty
if she goes on her own and dates
somebody who's an idiot
it sounds like all these other things
aren't the problem it sounds like the
problem is you feel guilty about
everything
because you haven't taken ownership of
what elsa wants
and who elsa is
yep yeah you're right
and it's super common it's culturally
appropriate it's super common in any
culture
for
the wife to be the person responsible
for making sure everybody else is at
peace
just like the last color every drink is
full everyone else has food everything's
cleaned up
but um what do i do if
if
if i decide not to take her in and then
my husband
he's not gonna be happy about it and
i don't know is he gonna be is he gonna
be
more unhappy
that the woman he loves and the woman he
married is miserable
or is he gonna be more unhappy
that his sister who's 28 years old and
is choosing not to get her own one
bedroom apartment somewhere
is at this point i don't know because
all
throughout our marriage um i always feel
like he's he's uh always taking care of
his parents
and and i get that i get that as
culturally that's culturally appropriate
i get that and that's also i mean it's
respectful i mean i get that yeah
have you and him sat down and said
where are we headed what is our marriage
going to look like what are we doing
and we have um and we have
and and
and
i don't know i don't know because if i
decide not to take her and i feel like
he's going to keep pushing and but
you're oh you're always going to feel
you're always going to feel you're going
to have to make p
there is not an outcome here where you
feel okay where you go ah i win
or
ah that's the way that's gonna be that's
not gonna happen
i i wanted to ask you they um
they plan on not telling my other
sister-in-law and
i'm not like that's their problem like
i'm not gonna get in the middle of that
but
but i feel like they should let my
sister-in-law know that her husband is
doing
her brother hasn't confronted this man
no who's sexually assaulting his sister
he's he's he told me that he's gonna do
it eventually but first he wants um my
sister-in-law to move in with us
i mean i i get that there's a safety
thing involved there i get that
it feels like everything's out of whack
it feels like there's a lot of
things being done to keep up appearances
there's a lot of things being done
because quote unquote that's the way
we're supposed to do them
and underneath the appearances and
underneath the
that's the way we're supposed to do them
is a wife who's drowning
is a woman who's being sexually
assaulted and is going unaddressed
right yes
and also that
she doesn't want
she he doesn't want to hurt my
my married sister-in-law's feelings he's
not hurting him her husband who sucks is
yeah not him
he needs to man that dude he's
i mean he sounds like an incredible like
a good man
who just he's good but i feel like he's
too good like he's got things out of
whack that's right like the priorities
are out i would love to just spend some
time and have coffee with him and listen
and learn from him i guarantee he's got
a wealth of wisdom but right now his
priorities are out of whack
i get honoring and taking care of your
parents i get that
i get honoring and loving taking care of
your sister she's 28 years old
she's gonna ha where's she gonna meet
somebody living in your i mean she's got
never mind she's got to
take the reins and be an adult
she has yeah and i feel like it's gonna
help her grow up it's gonna help all
those things it's gonna help all those
things yeah
but
at the end of the day here's the things
you got to know
there is no move here that you're going
to just feel wonderful and great
there's not
so you're going to have to decide
what's the right thing for me in this
situation what's the right thing for our
marriage what's the right thing for five
years from now 10 years so now we're
going to bring a kid into this mess
i also it's going to sound crazy i've
got sympathy for your husband he feels
like he is trapped
between
western world between cultural
obligations between
not wanting to blow things up but his
sister's husband just blew up everything
just turns into a mess
and so at some point you've heard me say
this once i'll say it 100 times you got
to turn all the lights on stop the music
and say what are we doing
where do i rank with you i am your wife
i want our own space
i want us to be on the same page about
how we're going to honor your parents
and my parents how much money we're
sending how much we talk to them
i want to be on the same page with you i
want to speak into and have equal weight
with
how are we going to support your sister
how are we going to love your sister i
want to call the police because my
sister got sexually assaulted
i want to go over to their house with
you now and address this in person
we're not blowing up anything he blew it
up it's already blown up
we're showing up with
the fire trucks
but it sounds like everything's just a
mess i'm trying to cover here flip on
the lights and say enough's enough's
enough
here's what i want you to do elsa i want
you to write this stuff down in order
for yourself
and i want you to go have an honest
direct conversation and you're going to
have to have this in your back pocket
your or what
because social stands are good marriage
stands are great
but there has to be an oral what because
he may look at you and say no
my sister is moving in here and if you
don't like it you leave
i am going to send 60 of our paycheck to
my parents every month if you don't like
that you leave
have your or what have it in your heart
have it ready
and make sure you've got people that you
can talk to because it's a mess and i
know it's a mess
thank you so much for call elsa my
heart's with you man i know this is
tough tough tough tough tough tough when
we get caught between family and love
and abuse and culture it's hard hard
hard and if you're one of my you know
listeners who hasn't had
experiences with the rich latin american
culture
you suggest you should just shut up
there's a lot of history here
but i do think
you elsa
are number one at that table
period
all right as we wrap up today's show
we're gonna go to james's second
favorite song of
all time i didn't strike you as a
leanne womack fan but
here we go and james
i hope you dance too that sounds like an
insult
oh if you dance oh you told me that's
country music insults baby
sun goes like this i hope you never lose
your sense of wonder well now that's
actually a good song
you get your fill to eat but always keep
that hunger
diabetes may you never take one single
breath for granted god forbid love ever
leave you empty-handed i hope you still
feel small when you stand by the ocean
whenever one door closes i hope one more
opens this is like a song of like a
pillow sings like are crocheted into
like bathrooms
promise me that you'll give faith a
fighting chance and when you get the
choice to sit out or dance
[Music]
i hope you dance
i literally just threw up in my mouth
right here on the dr john delaney show
[Music]